looking back now it's hard to believe
there ever was a time when the standard
high-rise was so universally beloved and
in its prime the century of the
high-rise the whole trend started with
apartments like the luxurious Dakota
building it set an example for the
middle class to also desire vertical
living by mid-century the state funded
high-rise was an iconic emblem of the
period as one of the most commonly built
forms of the century numerous and myriad
a blunt instrument in the century-long
struggle to find a place less obscure
for those in the middle somewhere
between the rich and the poor
how did the publicly subsidized
high-rise building go then from solving
the problems of the 20th century to
being blamed for them the invention of
reinforced concrete was the first
ingredient it's early residential use on
a Japanese island is expedient
Mitsubishi build these tower blocks for
workers mining coal under the sea
concrete fends off typhoons but living
conditions here are not new they're
horrific to the nth degree
meanwhile the architect of Corbusier
envisions a more utopic use for concrete
he invents towers in the park a design
which would help the high-rise formula
reach its peak it takes a third
invention to make the high-rise truly
contagious public housing a new idea for
this century it's courageous it happens
first in socialist read vienna at a mass
scale while in the US the approach is
more cautious under the great
depressions vale mayor LaGuardia builds
the first houses with New Deal money to
progress but proves that public housing
is possible even in the chief capital of
capitalist us
master builder Robert Moses quickly gets
to work the war is over the global
population booms and for the next two
decades the mass housing experiment
blooms governments around the globe
become committed to social equity with
efforts ranging from full public
ownership to public-private affinity
the soviets call it housing for the new
man the capitalists call it a
middle-income housing plan the New York
City Housing Authority becomes home to
five percent of the city's population
Britain's four million public sector
dwellings add to this mass housing
equation rivaling the Soviet bloc where
Khrushchev's uniform prefab concrete
slabs expand through multiplication from
Russia to Germany to Mongolia sixty
million people today still live in this
high-rise cornucopia publicly sponsored
housing isn't everywhere the diet beyond
Europe North America and the Soviet
Union high-rise development is rampantly
private except for Singapore Hong Kong
and isolated experiments such as Tata
loco in Mexico City with ancient Aztec
inheritance
the mass housing experiment is a
decade's long story of idealism and
destruction robert Moses's urban renewal
obliterates neighborhoods and boosts the
crime and segregation it claims to put
in reduction it leaves an often brutal
legacy take the Bronx air rights
building over yards of rail are the
bridge towers over a highway the noise
the fumes such an epic fail at ronan
point in the UK a prefab building is so
shoddily built it comes down on itself
taking with it five lives
the high-rise honeymoon is ending what
survives
alongside the vertical housing movement
a conflicting phenomenon urban sprawl
has matured the white middle-class flees
downtown on the highways planners such
as Robert Moses secured now many
high-rise neighborhoods instead of
housing this idealized middle-class have
become warehouses for their racialized
poor neglected by the state on mass the
building's fall apart from mismanagement
crime corruption and abandonment some
communities fight back now blaming the
buildings for the social failures
becomes the new credo the demolitions
begin here with the once admired st.
Louis's Pruitt Vigo down comes the
concrete Berlin Wall with it the Soviet
Union and its mass housing construction
sprawl yet in Singapore and Hong Kong
state-sponsored housing mounts it's the
shangri-la of mass housing by some
experts accounts on a global scale
it's a dawning of a new millennial age
towers made of glass rise and with them
another ideology takes center stage
housing is no longer built as a tool for
social equity and equilibrium it's now a
financial instrument of market
capitalism they call it the condominium